there's a life cycle right your teens
your 20s your 30s and so on and every
phase is a little bit different or quite
a bit different and people have asked me
uh in their 20s what is good advice for
their 20s you are about to go
independent you were dependent on others
and now others are going to become
dependent on you and you're going to
work and you're going to learn and
you're going to try to be successful
this whole different phase in your life
the best thing I can say is make your
work and your passion the same thing and
don't forget about the money part okay
now you're in a different phase of your
life you're in the phase of your life
that um your job is getting more serious
your responsibilities are going to get
more serious perhaps your uh
relationships are going to get more
serious this is a stage of your life
where you might be choosing a partner
and you may be having children and as
you're choosing a partner and having
children you're going to deal with the
work life balance issue and so the bit
of advice that I want to convey at that
is that you can look at that um as oh I
have to choose between giving up my work
hours and I have to choose to so to have
a quality of life you have to choose
less if you know how to get more of an
out of an hour you can have more life in
life and so that there are things that
you can do in my book principles I wrote
some of those things down that you can
be more efficient more effective and you
can get more out of life so the
trade-off is less okay what what would I
recommend first of all I recommend for
every phase of your life meditation if
you can meditate and you have the
calmness and the equinity to look at
that I think that that's an important
thing and then I think also that if you
think about the relationships that
you're in that then may be more
strained um to differentiate those
relationships who are the people that
you want to be around and how do you
work with them to get you through those
issues h